nous sommes en direct avec lisa mattson
ancienne vice présidente du parti
écologiste suisse est membre du conseil
des états la chambre haute de la
confédération helvétique hills à matane
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france arnould ac2 référendum
c'est une surprise pour vous c'est une
déception en tous les cas parce que on a
obtenu une majorité de la population des
attentes et des votantes qui qui
revendique le fait que le l'éthique des
règles morales le respect des droits
humains doivent passer avant le profit à
tout prix
et malheureusement on a un système qui
s'apparente un peu à celui des états
unis qui fait que si il y à une majorité
dans un canton il bascule de l'autre
côté malgré la majorité de la population
et donc c'est un refus
au final en résultats alors concernant
le premier texte 1 qui qui portait
justement sur ces armes sur l'arrêt du
financement d
des marchands d'armes est ce que c'est
un échec pour cette initiative qui a été
porté par le groupe pour une suisse sans
armée et les partis de gauche
c'est un échec mais on a permis
d'aborder un débat très importante avant
celui de nous sommes banques centrales
la banque nationale suisse qui vous
savez m brasse vraiment des centaines de
milliards de francs à l'aide d'un
assistant adam l'auteur extrêmement
élevé dont des investissements aussi de
plusieurs milliards dans l'armement et
c'est une question qu'on doit se poser
en tant que collectivité est ce que
c'est la manière dont cet instrument de
l'état doit agir dans sa politique
monétaire de soutenir des industries
d'armement
de la même manière qu'il soutient des
industries des chasses pour vous le
climat et je pense qu'il y en ait décidé
maintenant d'accorder notre politique
monétaire et notre politique générale
lisa mazzone vous êtes ancien vice
présidente du parti écologiste suisse la
deuxième initiative
je pensais était scrutée de près
d'ailleurs on a vu un durant serait
faire la campagne en tout cas concernant
ce référendum des affiches qui disait
que ce texte sur les multinationales
responsable je cite raté sa cible
qu'elle était justement les arguments du
nom à cette initiative
on a été confronté à des arguments qui a
été en grande partie des contrevérités
en a entendu qu'une soyons des sols à
prendre cette fois on savait pas lequel
en france vous allez une loi vigilance
qui va dans le même sens
on voit aussi des progrès au cours en
grande-bretagne canada
et puis on a été confronté à l'argument
de la proportionnalité on nous a dit les
entreprises suisses ne doivent pas
répondre de leurs actes à l'étranger
dans pas répondre des actes des
entreprises qu'elles contrôlent
il faut que ça se passe sur place donc
dans les pays en question le problème il
est évident c'est que dans ces pays là
on a souvent des états de droit qui sont
déficients
et donc les victimes dont n'obtiennent
jamais justice et pourtant la société
mère basée en suisse qui nous apportent
de l'argent suisse qu'on a un lien
direct avec elle aurait pu éviter des
graves atteintes aux droits zone est ce
que vous avez le sentiment qu'à suisse
aujourd'hui fait primer la santé de son
tissu économique sur les droits aux
humains et les devoirs environnementaux
la période du comité même une période
très incertaine
il ya beaucoup de gens qui réfléchissent
à leur avenir est ce qu'ils vont perdre
leurs emplois qui sont menacés dans leur
quotidien économique
et ça je le comprends parfaitement
malheureusement ça dépend cette
initiative très légèrement puisque on a
quand même une majorité de la population
qui la soutient mais cette peur elle et
part fonder parce que l'on se fait qu'au
contraire c'est plutôt un atout pour nos
entreprises de pouvoir garantir avec des
règles des lois qu elles sont
respectueuses des droits humains en fait
qu'elles n'ont rien à se reprocher on
l'avait vécu en suisse sur les questions
des normes contre la corruption on a eu
beaucoup de temps allez allez mettre en
vigueur et en application ce qui se
faisait aux états unis et un moment
c'était plus tenable pour notre économie
de ne pas avoir de tel dans contre la
corruption je pense qu'on va de toute
façon être ramenés tôt ou tard à nous
adapter un trend internationale qui veut
que les droits humains puissent être
respectés y compris à l'étranger le
l'économie globalisée ne peut pas se
faire sur le volume merci beaucoup en
tout cas lisa mazzone d'avoir répondu à
nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes conseillère
aux états et ancien vice président du
parti écologiste suisse